headed to Portland early-morning red-eye
back
grinding on this Monday let's do it
[Music]
producers who are badass at what they do
yep they don't play well with others
[Music]
it's so impressive it's literally the
first time I've ever heard such a thing
already been covered based on what you
guys know that me based on what you know
about them where do you think you want
me to go offense I am for you to triple
down on your strengths and Punk your
weaknesses
I see yeah I may go a little bit Thank
You economy on it too it's funny I had a
really interesting text conversation
with AJ had a six hour flight this
morning we're talking about Jamal Adams
the Jets rookie phenom I love this kid
so much charisma we're talking about
intangibles I really really really want
to talk about the grey the intangibles
really the reason why I have not been
physically gifted but still have won a
lot of games because it's the intangible
is it's not the black and white got to
go on stage here in Portland's real
pleasure man
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys all just let's welcome to the
stage mr. Garrety
[ __ ] tangibles like the stuff you
can't measure you can't measure this
right you can measure how strong a fast
you can measure help IQ smart you can
measure how many hours you can measure
all the black and white it's the great
intangibles that are really the
fundamental difference as you push
yourself to be a better [ __ ] human
being better things start happening for
you in your actual selfish business
wants and needs and it comes from
kindness it comes from patience comes
from a million different places but then
it's like little intangibles I never
have to rush to the air you know I'm
gonna quit okay anybody are we done
yes it's do it the truth is undefeated
truth wins and so I've become
comfortable in that truth even at my own
peril I speak about my shortcomings a
lot more than I used to because if
you're gonna embrace they got embrace it
fully you know it's playing a different
game than everybody else is playing it
is that thing that makes people win
about to do this interview for these
guys for what the bloggers yeah social
just content yeah just stuff to do some
[ __ ] contents state onstage forever
got a big fire back home that I got
addressed kind of phone call kind of get
to the airport meet-and-greet it's still
great oh ok so I run this nap
yeah it's she's a gangster that's your
girl yeah maybe dating her like she's
really your girl it's not exactly right
Donna makes it awesome but to make it
better do you want people to come into
the store what's up we want people to
come to the business right let me throw
a really interesting curveball on you
you should literally take the account
right now look at it and be like hey
guys what can I do here
to make it better for you like one of
the craziest moves in social that I find
fascinating is just asking the audience
what they want you will be blown away by
how much feedback you'll get that will
unlock right literally like hey it's
Rhoda you know you know I run the
[ __ ] [ __ ] for this store like what up
like I need you guys are telling now you
got a snapchat so Jim now you could just
keep holding it down so you're [ __ ]
good you don't have to depend of second
[ __ ] anymore right
so you're just holding it down and
you're like [ __ ] throat Oh what up
like [ __ ] run [ __ ] here like what do
you guys want on this snapchat and
here's what's gonna happen
80% of them gonna be like give us free
[ __ ] no [ __ ] there clearly you know
exactly which you can mix in by the way
I'm on a whole kick at Wine Library now
every Saturday we're just giving away
ten dollars worth of gourmet food I'm
like doing it like the ROI actually
works so like giving away free [ __ ]
people like to [ __ ] on it it's kind of
clever if you've got something good
because the cost of entry is low but
look you know this people want
entertainment and you're [ __ ]
entertaining just on your [ __ ] face
you know
I believe you so just be a meanie
remember when I talked about bet on our
strengths and our weaknesses
go [ __ ] all Bill & Ted's Excellent
Adventure
you know like you I could taste it from
this far away you'd be entertaining as
[ __ ] and it will bring people make every
[ __ ] person want to watch it for you
and [ __ ] Larry the [ __ ] mop guy
cuz he's funny like create a [ __ ]
sitcom bro yeah go ahead bro
[Applause]
he never heard of me before today you
guys want to see on this so tell him
tell him what you [ __ ] want that's
okay right it's got it the proof
approved from the top
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
and of course when was the first time
that you ever realized that you could
just really speak honest and you were
like oh this feels right this feels good
I think the most honest place I've ever
been was in competition thank you
brother
what's your name my name's James take
care guys bye chicken thank you brother
thank you take care you know like the
place where I'm most honest was always
where I was competing tennis gym class
hockey was a very competitive thing in
my high school back in her basketball
pink pumps one business but I started to
be in business I got very competitive I
look at it as a sport so if I go on pill
right when I get competitive I go like a
bull like it comes red I guess when I
started really being out there there's a
personality in my mid-30s the camera
brought a level of like I know
somebody's watching this in 39 years and
I'm fascinated by that I don't know I
think I'm trying to discover the answer
for you in the audience I don't know I
can tell you that I continue to build
momentum on it yeah I don't know when I
first started doing it like going really
there yeah but I definitely do it more
than ever
cuz it's right the truth is undefeated
truth wins and so I've become
comfortable in that truth even at my own
peril I speak about my shortcomings a
lot more than I used to because if
you're gonna brace again a brace
employee
[Music]
[Music]
cancers cancer that's why I always
trying to be the best at what I do
because I want nobody to have leverage
over me